[Music]
hello
and thank you for joining today
my name is stephanie whitland i am one
of the admissions officers
at the stanford graduate school of
business and i'm delighted today
to be here to go through
your journey uh from mina to stanford
we have a panel of um recent alums
who will be sharing their experience
with you
and we're eager to get started
and so for today's event what we're
really going to do
is give you a brief introduction to
the stanford community the gsb community
i want to introduce you to our panelists
who
will be speaking with you today and
sharing their experience
we will be taking q a throughout the
session
and if we don't get to any of your
questions today
feel free to reach out to our admissions
officers
afterwards you're certainly welcome to
do so and email us
at any time we're here to help you
through your journey
as we look at this opportunity what i
wanted to share most importantly is the
global community that awaits you so the
stanford gsb
is very focused on creating a
diverse class and that's diverse in
the broadest sense of the term
culturally
background socioeconomic status
ethnicity
and so we really do appreciate
individuals coming with different
perspectives experiences and backgrounds
we have over 43 percent of our class
are international students representing
66 countries
and this is for the class of mba 2021
and over 70 languages spoken so the
broad experience that you might have
is certainly worth considering
uh there are a number of clubs and
organizations that we have
on campus as well certainly want to
highlight
um the middle east north africa club the
meena
club
for those of you who are interested in
getting involved
and again i want to take this
opportunity to
welcome our panelists who have joined us
today khalood
and yasmin thank you for taking the time
out of your day
to be here um i will start with kalut
since you're first on the uh
slide if you wouldn't mind just giving a
brief break
background um to introduce yourself i'd
appreciate that
of course thank you stephanie and
welcome everyone
my name is uh and i'm from saudi arabia
uh prior to dsb i was working in aramco
which is saudis oil company
i was working at their corporate venture
capital arm so i'm
investing in technologies mainly in oil
and gas
after gsb i worked
for a year in a venture capital firm in
silicon valley
then i came back to saudi and now i'm
working
in nyong which is the new futuristic
city that saudi arabia is building
and mainly focused on tech and
innovation
thank you so much i have so many
questions for you as it relates to that
but that's not what this session
is for so let's move on to yasmin
um thank you for being here um and
welcome
of course thank you for having us um so
as stephanie mentioned
i'm yasmin i graduated from the gsb in
2018 so i was just a year
ahead of colludes i'm originally from
egypt
i moved to the us for the gsb so i was
living in cairo
right before starting the program uh i
worked for
citadel capital which was a private
equity firm
based in egypt um operating throughout
north and east africa for six years
prior to joining the gsb
and since graduating um i
have transitioned into tech so i'm a
senior product manager
at pinterest which is a tech company
that you may have heard of
based out of san francisco
great thank you so much thank you both
so much for being here
what really got you thinking about
stanford especially
coming from the mena region um if you
can just share
what that experience was like or how you
explored
um the gsb is a possible option for you
uh do you mind starting
happy too um i think for me my
background was an
entrepreneurship and venture capital so
i was kind of well aware
of uh silicon valley and i knew that i
wanted to go to stanford
um early on so it was a top priority
from the point of applying or starting
the whole
mba application process plus
i think one thing that maybe made me
kind of turn more towards stanford is i
had
a lot of alumni around me from leaders
or managers in the um
in the places that i worked with were
like
um let's say community activities um
so i think just i was just well aware of
uh the values of the school and i like
it was definitely my first
option going into the whole process
okay great thank you yes man anything to
add for you
coming from egypt yeah sure
uh mine was a little different actually
so um as i mentioned i worked in
financial services and um i grew up in
dubai
and then was living in egypt and for the
majority of my life there were like
three general tracks that people took
for their careers like
you either became a physician or an
engineer or you worked in
business finance uh in some regard
um and the impetus for me to go to grad
school was to actually figure out
if financial services was the place i i
actually wanted to be
or did i just like end up there because
i wasn't an engineer and i wasn't a
doctor
um and so the reason i chose the gcp
specifically is because i wanted to
abstract away from the confines of
like what success is defined as where
i'm from
like where egypt is because those are
basically the three industries
um and so i felt like the gsb was the
furthest thing away from
what i'm accustomed to and like would
really stretch my thinking there were
other schools i was considering
that i felt like i would probably end up
doing what i knew
how to do well um which was financial
services at the time and so
it wasn't as intentional as me saying
like i want to break into tech
therefore i will go to the gsb but it
was like the gsb is going to give me
that exposure to all these different
types of roles and jobs and industries
that i've never
come close to and that exploration was
really the appeal for me
thank you thank you for sharing i think
what i'll do now to make this just a
little bit more intimate so we can see
one another i'm gonna stop my screen and
so that'll just be the three of us and
that'll be
a little bit easier for folks to see as
well
um i'll still take questions so for
those of you who have joined us today
please do um add any questions that you
might have for
collude or yes men in the q a box
so i appreciate you both
sharing your experience of exploring why
stanford could you tell me what the
culture shift might have looked like for
you once you
joined the community coming from the
mena region was there anything that was
a surprise
and anything you could share with the
community that might be helpful as
they're exploring
making uh that kind of shift to come to
the us
for their graduate degree
uh yes do you want to start do you have
anything uh
sure it's a little it's a tough question
um
i think i think there are a lot of so at
the very baseline level there's a lot of
cultural references i didn't know when i
moved to the us i don't know that it's
unique to the gsb but i think it's just
like moving to a new country
um there are also a lot of like norms
like
12 p.m lunch time blew my mind where i'm
from we don't eat
at noon like we have lunch at like four
um
so um there were just like small
things that you sort of like adjust to
um
my biggest adjustment is when i first
moved to the u.s someone asked me if i
liked the outdoors and i was like sure i
like to sit on the beach
and um ride a bike and they meant like
mountain climbing
um and so that's like a big thing in
california and so my definition of the
outdoors was really
different um so there are a lot of like
cute little things
um but then um i think
probably one of the bigger things was um
demeanor in class
so where i went to school as a kid you
sort of were
quiet in class like you sat down you
took notes you didn't really
speak unless you had a question uh like
that was really like
you didn't understand something that's
when you would raise your hand and talk
whereas the gsb really has this culture
of participation
and actively speaking and debating in
class which was
very different than anything i had ever
been exposed to and i think there was
like a decent adjustment for me
in my first quarter to just actually
speak up in class because i really
wasn't
it wasn't like second nature to me at
all
that's a great point thank you
um one thing to add so i fully agree
with you
on like the structure or the format
of teaching is very different in the us
from
the middle east one thing on the
cultural aspect i think
i coming to gsb i was very worried about
expending ramadan let's say the month of
ramadan which we usually fast in
i was very worried about how am i going
to spend it alone as a student
and it turned out to be one of the best
experiences i had because we made a pact
amongst
like us the like mina club um group
of no one having to do um
to break their fast alone and um
we ended up forming kind of a community
or a bond with not just
like muslims or people from the mina but
everyone across this
the schools started joining um so
until today i actually remember these
days and i think um it's
kind of part of sharing our culture with
the students across the university
thank you um to add to that
is there anything you might share with
the audience or the attendees about
um advice as they're thinking about the
transition
maybe anything that as you're looking
back best prepared you
um other than you know keeping an open
mind and knowing what the culture of the
gsb
offers
i think mine was
if you end up at the gsb don't be afraid
to share who you are and where you're
from
um i think it took me a while to like
very openly talk about
being egyptian what that meant uh for me
as a person
uh what that meant for me as someone who
doesn't drink
um and there's just like a lot of
things about me that i sort of like kept
guarded at first because i was like oh i
just want to fit in and like i want
you know to like feel like i'm the same
as everyone around me but
um it's actually like one of the it's a
very unique time in my life where like
people really want to know the unique
things about you and they're so
interested to learn about
where you're from and like what makes
you you and that's
honestly the most beautiful thing about
the gsb in that community and so
it wasn't until i did my my talk so
there's this
um thing that if you talk to anyone who
went to the gsb they'll talk to you
about
uh which is called talk where you
basically get up in front of your
classmates
and share your life story and it could
be whatever it is you want and it's a
very intimate setting
with 300 of your closest friends um and
you just share your story and i talked
about living through
the egyptian revolution and um and what
that did to me and my family
and um and it just like
changed my experience at the gsb when i
opened up people who had been hanging
out with for a very long time didn't
know
anything about me or that background and
i feel like
that was the thing that sort of
transitioned me into actually just being
like you know what i'm just gonna own
where i'm from and what i who i am as a
person
and it just it and it brought me closer
to people who were
already my friends um and honestly just
made me a lot more comfortable with who
i am so like
don't feel like you need to conform at
the gb or anywhere honestly but
especially at the gsb
it's a really thoughtful reflection
because i do believe
that many students regardless of your
background or experience
come to the gsb and have a lot to offer
which is why we
have you as part of the class we know
that you'll contribute to that
patchwork and i i'm glad to hear that
you were able to
ex you know certainly share
that that part of you with the rest of
the community
collude would you have anything to add
to that um in terms of
looking back on your transition and what
that was like
um i think i think for me it was
um i was i was at the gsb
at a time where it was also very
critical for saudi as that was
it was going through major reforms in
fact
in the my first week of gsb was when
saudi and
lifted the ban of women driving
um so i think for me it was also
it was a tough two years
where saudi was in the media whether
unpositive or negative
and i i think it was mainly
like i i don't think i was still
comfortable
like talking in public about it yet i
enjoyed having one-on-one conversations
with students
and in my second oh actually my first
year
i actually had or second year i had uh
one of my classmates come back with me
to saudi during
winter break and taking her across
um and for me as well it was
experiencing a new saudi because there
were a lot of reforms at the time
um so i think just sharing a bit of
home with students was
was very meaningful
uh for me
great thank you um i'm going to go ahead
and
take some questions from the q a one
that's kind of
popped up um at the top uh asks about
being able to briefly indicate how
your mba helped you to do your
respective shift and i presume that they
are referring to your shift in industry
um can either of you speak to that i
know you both
kind of adjusted where you were
previously to where you
currently are so how how did the gsb
help you make that shift
uh yes man i'll start with you
yeah absolutely um yeah there is no
doubt in my mind that there's 100
no way i would have been where i am
right now had i not gone to stanford
um the reason being um
while i was in egypt well one i didn't
know what i wanted to do right so like
the concept of tech or like breaking
into tech wasn't even a thought that i
had so
um having that exposure was something
that i got
through my summer internship through
talking to people in my class who came
from that industry
from talking to alumni from talking to
career advisors at the gsc
so all those conversations sort of
helped me
figure out what it is i wanted to test
or potentially do next once i graduated
so that was the first
thing um the second thing is um
when you work in the mena region or any
other
area outside of the us moving into a u.s
job is
pretty difficult for many reasons um
most notably
because of visa reasons um and so i
think being
at the gsb and having the benefit of opt
which is
um i forget what it stands for optional
practical training you think
um allows you to secure a job
essentially one year
or uh depending on your degree maybe
more um
after graduation so that that was
another like benefit of
pursuing a graduate degree um and third
and
quite honestly most importantly even if
you have
like even if you're a us citizen living
in the mean region and you're trying to
move over
sorry about that um you
um it's actually really hard to break
into these drops especially if you're
transitioning your industry like if i
was going from pe to pe maybe i'd have a
better chance but if i'm trying to break
into a new industry where i don't
necessarily have the relevant experience
that's really difficult and that's where
the alumni network was my saving grace
like i emailed people who went to the
gsb who had those jobs or who had done
similar transitions
talked to them got advice from them a
lot of them referred me for
roles um and so recruiting just like
is very different because you need to
get your foot in the door and i don't
think you can
you can do that if you're kind of like
you don't have access to that network
um so for all of those reasons um
i i don't think i could have gotten this
job and when i was based in egypt i was
even trying to just
same industry like i wasn't even trying
to change my industry just
move out of the country um it's it was
impossible like i couldn't even land
an interview at the time and it was
really difficult
thank you for sharing thanks
yeah um in
i think for me it was more of so
it was more of the decision of whether i
wanted to stay in the u.s
or come back to saudi afterwards and
initially i was like i'm going to test
test out the us and um
we'll see maybe it's for me and maybe i
want to stay for a while
and then i realized that with the
reforms that are happening in saudi i
actually wanted to be part of it
so i decided to come back
after it i agree in terms of the
alumni network in saudi there's a very
strong alumni community in fact i'm in
the board of the
stanford alumni club in saudi um so it
was
definitely it just made the whole uh
career navigation process way way easier
because you have you will find an alumni
network
alumni in every institution in saudi
um so definitely that was a big help
that's that's great i know there have
been a couple questions
um related to that uh both why you
returned to the region
and then um were you able or did you
reach out to gsb alumni in the region um
for your move back to mina so what this
would be most
and and how did you connect how can you
talk a little bit about how that works
especially for people who might be
concerned if they do come to the u.s
but want to return
yes um so for me i i got connected with
alumni from when i was in school so
during alumni
events um usually the alumni
network at saudi would reach out to
students that are at stanford so you get
to meet
a lot of alums that come to campus um
and that
actually was the first thing that kind
of started conversations
uh and then once and even if you don't
have that
let's say that doesn't happen reaching
out to
the um um alumni the student alumni
association they will connect you with
the club
in the region and then they straight
away connect you
with any alum that will then know where
you want to go or what you're interested
in
um and we'll connect you to the
relevance people
um i think one thing that we are
starting at least in the
uh stanford alumni club in saudi arabia
is
like a a career uh or let's say
mentoring kind of program where we have
like recent
we send out names of recent grads um
or if someone wants to do a career shift
later on we kind of do like um
round table discussions around specific
interests
and that's kind of you can and then you
can take that further to land in
an opportunity
great glad to hear it glad to hear
you're active out there and
playing an active role in the alumni
organization
um we put in the chat because yasmin you
made the comment about opt
um just so you're all aware the mba
program
is now stem eligible so yes it used to
be a year
um now depending on um your situation
you you can actually stay in the us for
up to three years or 36 months so
that is an improvement over time um
can you talk a little bit about what the
experience was like in finding a summer
internship i'm not sure if i collected
information about
that from either of you so the year
between your first and second year
what did you explore either as it
relates to the transition you made
into the career you're currently at or
was it just an opportunity to
dabble in something else i'd love to
know what that experience was like and
how you navigated that process
um desmond do you want to start with
that one sure
um so i
wanted to try to do uh tech in my summer
internship that was like the
the first um that was the idea that i
had at least going into it
um there so on recruiting starts pretty
early
um and what that means is like some
companies
mostly like larger brands that you may
be aware of
um and like investment banks and
consulting firms will come to the gsb
and actually
do their interviews on campus and you
can talk to them etc um
so i skipped that i was just like i know
this is not what i want so i'm not gonna
spend my energy there um and that
happens early so it starts creating a
little bit of anxiety when you start
hearing that your friends already know
what they're doing for internship here
but i was just like i'm gonna stay true
to what i'm here to do
um and then finding an internship in
tech is
sometimes more difficult if you're if
you're looking at like an amazon which
is like a very large company
and they have established processes for
taking on interns every summer
that's much easier um but that's not
what i wanted either so i was really
you know making my life really difficult
for myself and
bugging the career management office a
lot with my problems
and they were always super helpful um
but essentially what i ended up doing is
um having a short list of tech companies
that i wanted to try to intern at
um and that made it a little focused for
me
um and then when i got nervous in the
middle i um
tried to also recruit for a finance
internship just
to be on the safe side i don't recommend
it it was a little stressful
ultimately um i ended up getting an
internship at a pe
fund um which made no sense and the
career office told me
this makes no sense you shouldn't go
there because you know how to do pe
um and then i ended up getting um an
internship
um at cruz um they are a self-driving
car company
based out of san francisco um and i
worked on their commercialization team
which is essentially the team that was
trying to determine
um once self-driving cars are actually
a fleet and they exist and they're
authorized which they currently are
in san francisco at least um how would
we monetize them
um and the way i got that internship
actually was through
one of the people who work at the cmc so
one of the advisors that i was talking
to pretty regularly
um just so happened to be talking to a
alum of the gsb who had was heading up
that team
at cruz um and she was like i need
someone with a financial background who
can also do strategy
and i did private equity in consulting
so she was like i have the perfect
person and she introduced us and i
interviewed and i got the internship so
it was
um i like to call it um a favor from the
cmc
um i'm sure there was like a little bit
of luck there but
um very long story short um
it was a lot of work but i think if you
if you decide
to stay focused on what it is that you
want um or what you're hoping to do and
then
really lean on the career management
office they can really really help you
especially if you don't have an existing
network in the industry that you want to
break into or in the us broadly which i
had neither honestly
yeah thank you so cmc is the career
management center yes and it um
it cannot be overstated that uh it's a
great resource um what was your
experience like
and that in that same transition it's an
internship
so i i coming from corporate venture
capital arm i know that i wanted to stay
in venture capital yet i didn't uh
i don't want to be in oil and gas or
energy i wanted to try something
new so um i started navigating the
process and honestly i got one of the
students at gsb introduced me to dp
and that's how i got to know the
fund that i ended up in training at um
and it was more like sector agnostic and
more early stage so it kind of fit
well into what i was looking for
um so got to have multiple conversations
with the gp
and then made the decision that i'll
intern that summer and i ended up
working
in that fund after graduation okay
all right very good i know we've talked
a lot about the
work experience that transition and so
forth i want to move a little bit into
something about the
experience when you were at the gsb um
did either of you participate in mina
the club
and if so what could you share and then
maybe more broadly to what other clubs
and activities did you get involved in
while you were at the gsb
um yes when you wanna i i saw you both
shake your head so clearly yeah i'm sure
you participated
um do you want to elaborate a little bit
more on
um both amina club and then other things
that you might have been involved in
sure um so i was on the leadership team
of the amina club
my second year at the gsb um and what
that meant is we love the club we
um myself and two other people in my
class um
one person was from palestine and one
person was from lebanon um
and what that meant is we organized
small group dinners um
where we did things with our class but
also with alumni
who would come back to um the bay area
as
mentioned uh we did during
ramadan which is like when people break
their fast um and
um this like hulu mentioned it wasn't
like uh just
us just the people from meena it was
literally like a lot of people across
our class
um and we shared things like that we
usually watch um
food that we typically eat that kind of
stuff and really brought a piece of home
uh to school with us um
we not through the club but because so
many people had
been interested in the club it kind of
gave birth
to a lebanon trip that happened and then
i did an egypt trip for 35 of my
classmates these are unofficial trips
not
sponsored by the gsd in any way but sort
of because the community was created and
people were so interested in the region
we actually
took people uh back um
and then we did a few um things around
just like charity drives um and just
like
sharing about some of the issues that
are happening in the middle east so i
specifically sit on a foundation
um for a charity in egypt
um that a lot of people were actually
super interested in
dedicating some time to and so i sort of
like played that connector role
and then we played a lot of roles in
admit weekend so this is when
people who are in coming to the gsb come
to campus
to visit the campus learn about the
school learn about the program meet
their future classmates
um and so we sort of had a booth we
welcomed everyone who's from the mena
region as well as from all other regions
um we had dinners with them shared our
experiences with them and sort of like
helped welcome them in the same way that
when i joined or when i was coming to
admit weekend
the folks from mina like the year ahead
of me
did the same thing and um we stayed
close with them when they started
uh and i think that's how cleveland i
actually met if i'm remembering
correctly but i'm not
i'm not 100 sure uh right that was how
we met is that right
yes okay
so yeah uh yeah i think the first time
was like
dinner or something yeah so like it's
it's nice because when you when you move
to a new country it's super
daunting but like you know that you
already have a meena family kind of
waiting for you
uh to welcome you and like help you and
it's um when you first get to the gsb
it's a beautiful feeling but there's a
lot of information being thrown at you
and you're also
moving halfway across the world for some
people um
so it was like a very nice thing for us
to offer because we had already been
there for a year and like we know what's
going on
and you can see the you know the fear
in people's eyes so yeah
great uh one thing that we did in our
year
is um we did the stanford mina forum
um which was a full uh day
forum that in which we hosted leaders
from mena
from public or private institutions also
entrepreneurs kind of leaders of change
from mina to come
and speak with stanford students
and then we had a session that was that
was more focused on art culture and food
and it was just it's actually one of
probably the most meaningful experiences
that i got out of the meena club because
it was
um it was it turned out into more of
like a networking also
for people from me now or students from
nina
so yeah that's great
um there is a question colluded for you
in the
q a which asks how did the stanford mba
prepare you to move from
vc and mena or vc in mina
to vc in the bay area and can you talk a
little bit about the recruitment support
i know we've talked a little bit but is
there anything else you might share
about how you made that transition into
the region here
yes i think um what's uh
what's interesting about the region here
is that or
specifically let's say the gcc is that
there's a lot of
changes that are happening and a lot of
reforms and tech adoption and i think
one thing that i was able to position
myself
in is how to bring in these technologies
to the region um so in a lot of ways
connecting them with
let's say the network that i used to
have prior to gsb
um in the region and bringing in these
technologies so more like technology
adoption and i think that was
that's mainly what helped me break in
into vc
in silicon valley coming from gcc
okay okay thank you
let's see here well uh
this is somewhat of an application
question but it but it's something
that's on their minds
osama asks what's one piece of advice
you'd share with applicants working on
there what matters most
essay for submission or or maybe just
general um guidance on
how you approach that part of the
application
um i can i can start um
that essay is probably one of the
hardest things i've had to do not
because it's
uh not because it's a hard prompt per se
but i
was not a reflective person uh before
i started at the gsb and i i wrote many
many drafts of that essay um
that went in very different directions
and i think if i were to think back the
one piece of advice i would give
is just be super honest with yourself
don't try to write an essay that you
think is gonna look good or is
what you think the school wants to hear
because i can tell you i don't work in
admissions
no one who has ever been to the gsb
knows what admissions wants to hear
they actually just want you to be honest
about yourself
um so don't try to make it look you know
like impressive or like here are all the
things i've achieved because they can
see that from your resume and from your
application itself
um and i think um after having met my
classmates
um and like learning about them and what
their stories are
my guess is like it really was shining
through in their application so just be
superbly honest actually um with
yourself
um and like really enjoy the exercise if
you're not a reflective person to
actually dig deep and figure out
what does matter to you most um and just
don't be afraid
to start over with your with your essay
like many many times
if you don't think it's right and have
close
people who know you really well as a
person
not like your manager at work like your
friends
people in your family read your essay
and like tell you that really does feel
like
you you are coming across on this piece
of paper
um because for me that was what really
helped um
like if i could show you some of the
drafts of my essays it was
pretty like not great in the beginning
and like you couldn't tell anything
about me as a person
um but my last my final version that i
like actually submitted
um to this day i read and i cry every
time i read it um
so it like not because of
tragedy in my life or anything but like
because i really did see the progression
in my drafts of
me really figuring out what my story is
or what i want it to be
um and so just really embrace the
exercise
excellent advice i'm not sure i could
say it any better myself when we talk on
the road too
about um giving pointers called anything
to add for you
as you were going through that
exploratory phase
honestly no i echo what is mean said 100
um just be authentic and genuine to
yourself
yeah yeah i think that's that's great
advice i always say
as an admissions officer that um
right for someone who who is genuinely
interested in wanting to learn about who
you are
right so we really do there's a human
reading that essay
and it's it is not right to impress but
right as if someone is genuinely wanting
to learn about the person that you
are and it is very reflective and and
can take some time and i do agree i've
been on the road and
heard from a number of alums over the
years that
um if you if you do it properly it is
the kind of essay that if you go back
and read
that it hopefully is something that is
so near and dear and core
to who you are that it is a thread that
follows you throughout your life and
it's nice to
to be able to reflect on that and look
back on that
so so thanks for sharing
um let's see i'm trying to think if
there's anything that i've
missed here that would be most important
um there's certainly a lot of
questions about how to connect with
alums in the mena region
and what i can say of course is that
well and i'll i'll let you add collude
but certainly
if you're admitted to the mba program we
are open to enabling you to speak with
students and alums
uh and certainly the communities are
very
strong and so is there anything else
that you might add
fluid in terms of communicating or
connecting with the
with the with the alumni organization
um nothing to add but if it's
if it's in our region and they want to
connect to me happy to
um happy to do that um
so that's yeah that could be a way
usually it comes if someone from the
school is connecting usually it comes
from the stanford students association
yeah um here's an interesting question
that just came in
from syed it says i'm from iran and i
really i'm really concerned about
sanctions and political conflicts
between the us and um
iran and there are certainly challenges
as it relates to the visa
process um can you either of you speak
to
what that even just like what the
experience was like for you
obviously you both applied pre-pandemics
so there's a few
few things that are might be a little
bit more challenging right now but
um maybe just elaborating on what that
process was like
for you and obtaining a visa
uh i'm happy to share so egypt is not in
the same
situation as iran obviously um so
applying for the visa was um was fine
and straightforward
i will say that while i was at the gsb
and i don't know this ran
until when hulu had started but um
there was a period of time where um the
us government
had sanctioned some countries beyond
just iran right like they had
uh several countries um in egypt was not
on the initial list but there was
talks of it like potentially being added
to that list um
a lot of my classmates were from country
so we had iraqi
classmates um who were on that list and
they weren't allowed
um and we also had someone from yemen um
and so
um i will say like in my
and this is just my opinion so take it
with a grain of salt the world is like a
very interesting place right now
um especially layered in with a pandemic
um and
these types of circumstances are sort of
like um
out of everyone's control what i will
tell you is once we were at the gsb
there were many many many resources for
us to
lean on it's unfortunate you end up in a
situation where
the international student office which
is outside of the gsb sort of like burns
all of international students
at stanford their guidance was like hey
just be
super conservative with your travel
decisions right now because
egypt might not be on the list today but
you may decide to travel
and then have issues coming back to the
u.s so we advise you to
you know exercise caution and perhaps
not travel but they were available
they consulted with us when we had
issues when we had visa
questions or problems they were there
now this is not
about getting you to the gsb i'm sure
you can speak to them
in advance of applying and i'm sure they
will support you to the best of their
abilities
um but visa problems and
travel restrictions are just an
unfortunate reality for
our region um and i will say that like
it's at least
comforting to know that there are
resources at stanford that will help you
um and um these people have a lot of
experience um with these types of issues
specifically i remember
um there was a classmate of ours who
traveled during winter break
um and had some issue actually
re-entering the us i forget
what the exact problem was um and they
like the students rallied and we like
reached out to the international student
center and we got them the help that
they needed so
there are a lot of people who want to
help you um so i think it's just a
matter of
um getting there and also deciding
whether
you think you can you know adjust
thank you thanks for sharing
um anything else collude from your
experience or
does it smell okay yeah
um so i would love to understand from
you as you
thought about your launch pad for your
future
how you weighed the cost and benefits of
either
staying in the us or returning to the
amino region
um how did you explore that as you were
thinking about launching after your gsb
career
um i know yes when you're here in the us
but is back in saudi arabia so um
you both have interesting perspectives
to share on that
um why don't we start with you since you
did go back to the region
if there was anything uh that was
compelling for you
to do so or how you weighed that
after the gsb
yeah i think for me it also goes back to
what matters most to you and why
and um i guess i
i because i went to the gsb at a time
where there were just
a lot of reforms that are happening and
kind of this
um dream that i always had uh started
happening while i was at gsb and i felt
like i was missing out on that
um and it's it felt like it's an
exciting time to go home
um and that that actually made it much
more
so like when i was in the us although i
did
feel like i was um kind of happy and
everything yet i didn't feel like i was
i felt like i could do more let's say
and
that mainly kind of shaped my decision
to
go back
and yes been for you what has it been
that um
compelled you to stay at least for the
short term
uh yeah so i i knew before i even
started the gsb that i didn't want to go
back
uh to egypt i had worked in dubai as
well as cairo
um and honestly i just um
yeah i didn't want to go back so i knew
that going in and i think that that
gave me some luxuries in terms of
decisions that i made
so i ended up taking on student debt
um to pay for a portion of of my gsb
tuition
which if i if i knew that i wanted to go
back to the um to egypt
or to the middle east that would have
been a harder sell for me personally
because
um the egyptian pound the year i started
at the gsb devalued 65
against the us dollar so if i had taken
dollar denominated debt and moved back
home that would
have been the most expensive degree
probably in the history of time
um and so i sort of like because i knew
that i wanted to stay i was like you
know what i can afford to take dollar
denominated debt
um which i then paid off uh once i
started and i think there was a
question that someone asked around um
like fellowships and scholarships
there are um i don't think there's a
dedicated gsb
one there is financial aid which i'm
sure stephanie can tell you all about
stanford is incredibly generous with
their financial aid and it's need-based
so that really helped me especially
because
my um home country's currency had just
devalued so it
my income actually just like looked
really small
on my application because the currency
had plummeted
um there is an africa based fellowship
um that stanford i believe offers um
that i think
ahmed in class actually got
as well as fellowships that you can get
in your home countries so egypt for
example has like
an harass com fellowship that people
often take
um so there are many opportunities for
scholarships i think
whether through stanford or otherwise um
most of them require you to go back to
the region so if you are planning to go
back to the region then you absolutely
should apply
um to those but because i knew i i
didn't want to then my main
outlet was financial aid my savings and
then debt which i then chose to take
on um because i knew i was staying
yeah um what i can elaborate on is we
actually
have a fellowship available
called the bold fellows program and it
is an opportunity for individuals
broadly defined in terms of diversity to
contribute so
we have sunsetted the stanford africa
program that you
had spoken about but that does not mean
that there still aren't other fellowship
funds available and absolutely as
jasmine mentioned
we are a need-based um financial
uh aid program and so from that
perspective yes
we certainly will work with you to make
sure that it is something that you can
afford
um one one other well so i wanted to
kind of
it hasn't been asked by the the the um
candidates in the q a but wanted to hear
from you if you could just talk about
maybe
your your favorite either experience and
or
class that you took while at the gsb i
always think it's fun to get sort of a
taste of
what the the experience for you and what
was most important or
maybe either most enjoyable or most
important to you
most meaningful um
do you want to start with that one
anything you can think of
sure um so i think for me
it was um i would say between the art of
self coaching and touchy feely
um and those classes i think they're um
i i think i used them until this day but
i think for me
it it contributed to the most growth
that
happened at the jsb um
and um whether it's learning about
actually mainly it was learning about
myself
my strengths and my weaknesses and how
can i bring that
um in my daily life or also the
corporate world
and i think it's what i learned from
these classes are things that
i use every day the
art of self coaching with ed barista i
mean i
i got into this habit of
reflection and journaling that i still
do
today um so yeah so for me those two
classes great
thank you yes
were um so i took this class called
rethinking purpose
which was a like abridged class um
and i think it just it really helped me
it was sort of why i went to grad school
it was just like i need to figure out
what i care about and what i want to do
with my life
beyond just like the job that i have um
so that class really really helped me
and gave me the tools to
figure that out um and then the other
one
sort of similar to one of the classes
mentioned
um was managing difficult conversations
um
and that class is it sort of like
stretched my thinking around
um how to like lead through influence as
opposed to
leading because you manage the person um
and
it has been invaluable as a product
manager
um because i don't i actually have to
influence all of these people i work
with but none of them actually report to
me so i can't sort of you know exercise
authority on anyone
um and it just has given me a bunch of
soft skills that i had never been
exposed to
or you know even thought i needed um
prior to taking the class and so yeah
i've
managed quote unquote a team of 12
people um
completely through influence and without
that class i don't think i
i could have done that
yeah there's um quite a few
opportunities for reflection and
and and all of that while you're at the
gsb for sure
which kind of leads us to probably a
final question that i'll ask of each of
you
um which was posted in the q a
um what would you say are the strengths
of the gsb mba program or what have they
been for you as you reflect
now on your experience and what were
those for you
um guess when you want to start yeah
sure
um 100 uh
it is the soft skills and the and
learning about interpersonal dynamics
like i just
um for what it's worth i got into three
different programs and went to three
different
advent weeks for those programs and
um all like most schools have
amazing curriculums amazing professors
they're amazing brands like like the
marginal difference is really small
what i didn't see anywhere else outside
of the gsd
was really these soft skill classes like
the just the sheer
number of them the people who come and
teach them
they're just completely different than
anything you will take at any other
school
um and so that i thought was
and and it's it's kind of why if you
talk to anyone in their second year
which is when they take electives and
they start getting exposure to these
classes
is when people fall in love with the gsb
and what it
and what it means to be there um and
then the other thing i will say is
um the ability to take classes uh we
call them across the street classes so i
have an interest in medicine
so actually took a bunch of classes that
counted towards my degree
at the stanford school of medicine and i
don't think i would have ever had the
opportunity to do that
at any other school um so in my mind
those are
probably the two largest selling points
yeah 100 agree with that one thing that
i'll add
is that gsb has a very collaborative
culture so let's say any new idea you
have
you can make amongst your class you can
get like 10 people that have worked in
this in that industry that will discuss
it with you
and i think um that's it has this very
unique culture of let's create something
collaboratively
um so um so i definitely think um
that's one of the also selling points
for gsb
well thank you both we are at time it
was
so wonderful to hear both of your
stories your insights your perspective
and your advice so thank you for sharing
with the audience and
to all of you who joined today thank you
for taking time whether it was
morning afternoon evening or otherwise
for you
we appreciate you making um time in
in your day to to join us and again
yasmine and kalu
thank you it was wonderful to hear from
you and wishing you all the best
so have a wonderful day and
thanks again